I'm not here to play the victim I'm here
to take responsibility
it's the tell-all the world has been
waiting for Jordan woods speaks out for
the first time since news broke about
her alleged hookup with Khloe
Kardashian's boyfriend
Tristan Thompson I'm no homewrecker
I would never try to hurt someone's home
especially someone that I love Kylie
Jenner's bestie sat down on Jada Pinkett
Smith's Facebook watch series read table
talk to explain what she says went down
that night at Tristan's house I'm not
thinking I shouldn't be here right and
that's my first step where I went wrong
and how I would feel if someone close to
me
is hanging on my ex house or yes the
father of my child I wouldn't I didn't
think about that that's the first part
of the problem Jordan claims that she
went to Tristan's house after the club
with a group of girls but she denies the
claims that they were making out in
public but you know the nights the
nights going on and never once was I
giving him a lap dance making out with
him sitting all over him it's just we're
all together we're in a group never once
did we leave the public area go to a
bedroom go to a bathroom
we're all in plain sight the next
morning Jordan says she talked to Kylie
and Khloe but she wasn't honest while
we're calling this part of her night out
with Tristan I had talked to Khloe and
she you know asked me was going on is
everything fine and in my head of trying
to forget that part of the story I was
just like you know no he was he was
chilling I was honest about being there
but I wasn't honest about the actions
that had taken place I know I was trying
to protect Khloe's heart
she doesn't deserve this either right
but it looks like Chloe isn't quite
ready to bury the hatchet minutes after
Jordans sit-down was posted
Chloe sounded off on Twitter writing why
are you lying at Jordan woods if you're
going to try and save yourself by going
public instead of calling me privately
to apologize first at least be honest
about your story bTW you are the reason
my family broke up and she wasn't done
with just the one tweet
here's her follow up Tristan is equally
to blame but Tristan is the father of my
child regardless of what he does to me I
won't do that to my daughter
he has been addressing this situation
privately if Tristan were to lie
publicly about what conspired then yes I
would address him publicly as well I
know I'm not the reason that Tristan and
Chloe are not together I'm just going to
ask you straight up okay
did you sleep with Tristan never god I
never thought another consideration
never happened just to clarify there has
been no communication with Tristan no
relationship over time the 21 year old
denies breaking up Chloe in Tristan's
happy home Jordan even got teary-eyed
talking about her broken bond with the
Kardashian family
she says she wishes the mistake was
handled internally the most
heartbreaking part the impact Jordans
actions have had on her own family
before the chat a source told et Jordan
felt her entire world had flipped upside
down so fast here's what Jordan had to
say about that every time you refresh
the page it's another person bullying me
or wishing death upon me if I was a weak
person I would have hurt myself it's
even hard for me to say this because
it's like you know everyone's safety is
is now we can't leave the house my
brother can't go to work like my sister
can go to school she's 12 years old
who has been friends with the Smith
family for years Thanks Jada for having
her on the show to tell her truth I'm
happy because now I feel like I'm free
et recently sat down with Jada who
opened up about her approach to these
hard sit downs at the read table there
have been times where he expended
one-on-one with people you have this way
of figuring out oh we can do it you can
do it right what how do you know how to
get into people's souls I think it's
just really the empathy like really
feeling people mm-hmm you know it's just
like when you're in a conversation you
just is that heart connect you know what
I mean it's not it's it's not um it's a
it's a conversation of like trying to
just get more understanding and build
love in connection I love connecting to
people there is nothing more pleasurable
to me right then sitting at a table
looking in someone's eyes and making an
energetic connection